Tom I don't know if you got a moment
just to give us a very quick update are
these letters coming in thick and fast
yeah they are as I say 27 to go through
oneexchange that I'm looking at right
here between Elliott morally and Prince
Charles this sep tember 2004 this is the
reply from charles really issuing a
number of issues surrounding the high
seas task force so surrounding fishing
issues the environments one phrase that
i can pick out within that incidentally
i'm also looking forward to the
publication of the Royal commission's
report on sustainable fishing I here on
my own grapevine that it may be quite
hard hitting which can only be a good
thing and I just hope that the powers
that be and the general public take note
of its findings so this is Prince
Charles certainly illustrating him being
tapped into the information that is
coming out of government things that are
upcoming and also expressing to a degree
a view not necessarily hugely
controversial or necessarily hugely
groundbreaking but expressing a view
nonetheless and in his own words we are
seeing for the first time just what he
has been saying to various government
departments and of course this comes
after a long legal battle started by the
Guardian newspaper ten years that has
taken to get to this point the pendulum
has swung many times between Prince
Charles's right to privacy and also the
principles that underpin the Freedom of
Information Act there as being the
Public Interest arguments that has seen
this today 27 letters coming out and
including that one the first kind of
incidents where we can see him writing
to Elliot Morley one of the labor
cabinet ministers certainly expressing
views on Environment policies and I
guess as these letters come out a lot of
people will be cross-checking to what
the government did at the time and
trying to establish whether or not it's
possible to establish if any influence
was brought to bear yes we've spoken to
people who were in Westminster at the
time you say that in some instances
these letters went straight to the top
of the ministerial in tray and that
things did happen in relation to
responding certainly to Prince Charles
just how he was viewed across government
of course is very difficult to gauge but
it is something of course that
the underpinning principles for the
monarchy is one of political neutrality
and therefore being seen to influence in
this way may be an uncomfortable process
and I know that we'll be hearing from
Clarence House more this afternoon as to
their feelings and perhaps their viewers
the context of these letters